GOOD MORNING.
AND WELCOME TO THE APRIL SIXTH
TWENTY. TWENTY TWO HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
. DOES NOT APPEAR THAT A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE- IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON MONITORING THIS
HEARING PLEASE COME TO ROOM FOR
SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. DO THE COVETED PANDEMIC
WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITH
MODIFIED COMMITTEE PROCEDURES.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT IN TODAY'S HEARING
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS REQUIRED.
FOR THE AUDIENCE OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM. ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO. IS PRESENT IN
THE HEARING ROOM IS ENCOURAGED
TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE. THE GOAL OF
HEARING AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN OUR TIME WHICH WILL ALSO
NOT TOLERATE ANY. DISRUPTIONS OR
DISORDERLY CONDUCT TO THE
COMMITTEE'S PROCEEDINGS.
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES. MAY
SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. THE
COMMITTEE. HAS NINE BILLS ON ITS
AGENDA. OR HAD NINE BILLS HAVE
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT BY
SOME NUMBER BIGELOW HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR AND WILL
NOT BE HEARD TODAY. AS A RESULT
WE HAVE EIGHT. BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY IN ORDER TO
ASSIST. ENSURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE. ITS BUSINESS AND A
LOT OF TIME WE ARE. LIMITING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS FOLLOWS. FOR
EACH BILL THERE WILL BE A
MAXIMUM OF TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WITH A
LIMIT OF TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS. AFTER WE HAVE HEARD
FROM THE PRIMARY WITNESSES THE
PUBLIC WILL HAVE A TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME. FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ON
EACH BILLS. STARTING WITH
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CORE HERE
IN THIS ROOM. OTHER WOMEN TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT. IF
ANY IN THEIR POSITION ON THE
BILL ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WILL BE
RULED OUT OF ORDER. IF YOU ARE
UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON THE
PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THIS WRITTEN TESTIMONY
WILL BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
PUBLIC RECORD. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS HEARING REMOTELY
AND WHO WISH TO CALL IN TO
REGISTER THEIR POSITION THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN THAT'S A
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR. FOUR FOUR. YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR COMPUTER
SCREEN. IF YOU WERE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. ON YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUNDS
TORSION. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. AT 916-319-2090. FOUR
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
TWENTY NINETY FOUR AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US AS
WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AT THIS POINT WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR IT
LATER IN THE MORNING. LATER IN
THE HEARING. THE FRST ITEM ON
THE AGENDA IS A BEING. TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ID LOCKER ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY WILL BE
OPERATING AT SUB COMMITTEE
CORRECT CORRECT THANK. MISTER
BAN. AND HAD TO GO TO A LOCAL.
MAY PRESENTABLE GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS BILL WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX WILL CREATE THE
CIVIC LEARNING OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT FUND T INCREASE
VOTER REGISTRATION IN COUNTIES
WITH THE LARGEST PERCENTAGES OF
UNREGISTERED ELIGIBLE VOTER. AND
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT FOR STUDENTS
AND SEVERAL PILOT COUNTIES. AS
YOU ALL KNOW VOTING IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT WAYS FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO EXPRESS OUR
VOICE HOWEVER UNTIL THE RECORD
INTEREST- GENERATED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION. FEWER
THAN 60% F ELIGIBLE VOTERS HAVE
EXERCISE THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN
STATEWIDE ELECTIONS IN THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS. HISTORICALLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
UNDER REPRESENTED IN THE VOTING
POPULATION. ADDITIONALLY THOUGH
CALIFORNIA'S RESTORED VOTING
RIGHTS THROUGH PROP SEVENTEEN TO
THE ROUGHLY FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ON PAROLE IN THE STATE
THERE IS NO OUT REACH TO ENSURE
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR SENTENCES OR REGISTER AND
VOTE. VOTING IS A HABITUAL
PROCESS BUT THE YOUNGEST GROUP
OF ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA VOTERS
HAVE THE LOWEST LEVEL OF
REGISTRATION. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX WILL ALSO ALLOW THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO WORK WITH
SEVERAL INTERESTED PILOT KERN
COUNTY'S CREATING AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE RESOURCE RESOURCES TO
LOCALLY DESIGNED AND EXECUTED.
US THE CIVIC AND VOTER
ENGAGEMENT PROGRAMS FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. THE FUTURE OF
OUR DEMOCRACY DEPENDS ON THE
ENGAGEMENT OF EVERY CITIZEN AND
STARTING WITH THE YOUNGEST
CALIFORNIANS TO TEACH THEM THE
IMPORTANCE OF VOTING AS A WAY TO
PARTICIPATE AND GUIDE THEIR
FUTURE HAS. NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX CREATES A SPECIFIC
FUND FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO DO TWO THINGS. IT WILL
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO REGISTRARS OF
VOTERS IN COUNTIES WITH FEWER
THAN 80% REGISTRATION SO THEY
CAN CREATE- SPECIFIC OUTREACH
PROGRAMS FOR THE MOST UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS IN THEIR
COUNTY. AND SUPPORTS HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAMS TO INCREASE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND PUBLIC COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT FROM VOTING ADVOCATES
AND SEVERAL COUNTY REGISTRARS.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE IS ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT OF
THIS BILL WE ARE ALSO ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND HER TEAM AND WE WILL
NOT SHARE ANY FUTURE. WITH WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IS JESSE SALINAS REGISTRAR
VOTERS FROM YOLO COUNTY AND BILL
JULIAN MY CONSTITUENTS AND
FORMER PUBLIC DEFENDER WHICH
WOULD LIKE TO. JENNER FIRST BILL
. SHERMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BILL JULIAN OKAY IT'S A
CONSTITUENT OF IS THAT WE ARE
CURRY HAVE A RETIRED ASSEMBLY
STAFF PERSON. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX ESTABLISHES THE
CIVIC LEARNING OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT FUND AS A PERMANENT
INSTITUTION UNDER THE PURVIEW OF
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO THE FRONT
LINES OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT THE
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS TO MEET
FACE TO FACE WITH VOTERS
ESPECIALLY YOUNG VOTERS. IT
BUILDS ON A CONCEPT THAT'S BEEN
IN THE LAW SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES BUT NEVER CONSISTENTLY
IMPLEMENTED OR ENFORCED MATT IS
THAT LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS BE
RESPONSIBLE TO REACH OUT TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO FULLY
REALIZE THAT MOST FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT THE RIGHT TO VOTE. WITH
THE HELP AND SUPPORT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RECOGNIZES
THERE BEEN A SERIES OF PROGRAMS
AND RULE SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES THAT REFLECTED THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENTION. THAT
THE SECRETARY STATE AND LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS COOPERATE TO
IMPROVE VOTER REGISTRATION AND
VOTER PARTICIPATION. ESPECIALLY
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE. THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE IMPROVED VOTER
REGISTRATION OR DISSIPATION BUT
THE FACT REMAINS. THAT A LARGE
PROPORTION OF A RESIDENT
ELIGIBLE VOTERS ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE NOT PARTICIPATING
ELECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA. BY
PROVIDING A PERMANENT
INSTITUTIONAL FRAMEWORK AND
PERMANENT FUNDING FOR
COORDINATING PROGRAMS THAT
REFLECT BOTH ENABLING LOCAL
CREATIVE PROGRAMS AND STATE
LEVEL OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE CAN EXPAND ON
THE UNPRECEDENTED UPSURGE IN
VOTER PARTICIPATION WE SAW THE
TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL ELECTION.
THIS BILL IS THE POLICY OF
FACILITATING COOPERATION BETWEEN
STATE AND LOCAL ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TO MAXIMIZE VOTER
PARTICIPATION ALL OF TURN OVER
MY COLLEAGUES- MISTER SALINAS
ABOUT THE DETAILS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS JESSE
SALINAS I AM YOLO COUNTY'S
ASSESSOR CLERK RECORDER AND
REGISTER VOTERS. I'M HERE THIS
MORNING AS MY RIGHT AS A
REGISTER OF VOTERS WEARING THAT
HAT- THESE PAST FEW YEARS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED JUST HOW FRAGILE
OUR DEMOCRACY IS. AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY HOW ELECTIONS WORK.
EXPERIENCE A LEARNING IS TRULY A
POWERFUL TOOL. WHAT BETTER WAY
TO TEACH FUTURE VOTERS THE
BEAUTY OF OUR ELECTION PROCESS
THAN TO EXPERIENCE IT UP CLOSE
AND PERSONAL. EITHER BY
PARTICIPATING AS AN ELECTION
WORKER AN OFFICIAL ELECTION OR
THROUGH AN ON CAMPUS STUDENT
ELECTION THAT CLOSELY MIRRORS
AND OFFICIAL ELECTION EXPERIENCE
. SUCH EXPERIENCES ONCE COUPLED
WITH THE STATE SEAL OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT WILL EMPOWER AND HELP
ENGAGE YOUNG VOTERS TO LEVELS
NOT PREVIOUSLY SEEN. IF PASSED
THIS BILL HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
ACHIEVE THREE IMPORTANT
OBJECTIVES WHAT INCREASED VOTER
REGISTRATION BY PROMOTING AND
LAUNCHING A NEW ERA OF
INNOVATIVE OUTREACH EFFORTS. TO
STRENGTHEN AND PROMOTE OUR
DEMOCRACY OF FUTURE VOTERS BY
PROVIDING A POWERFUL LINK TO THE
STATE SEAL OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. AND
THREE PROVIDE HANDS ON ELECTION
EXPERIENCES TO PARTICIPATING
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ENHANCING.
THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF AND
CONFIDENCE IN OUR ELECTION
PROCESS WHICH COULD OVER TIME
LEAD TO INCREASE TURNOUT OF
YOUNGER VOTERS AGES EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT'S A GROUP THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO HELP LIFT THEIR
PARTICIPATION RATE. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. FOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE
WILL. ONE SECOND. IS THEIR
PRIMARY WHAT WHEN IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. OKAY WE
DON'T HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THAT'S
GOOD TO HEAR WILL NOW MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF OR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
US AS A REMINDER MEMBERS THE
POPE OF MAXIMUM FIFTEEN MINUTES
IN TOTAL TIME FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT ALL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. WE WILL START HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
A POSITION. ON AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX. SEEING NONE WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ON AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX
MODERATED WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE
LINE WHICH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
ABSOLUTELY WE DO AND IN ORDER TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH BY NUMBER
WHAT WILL OPEN UP YOUR LIFE WHEN
WE ARE READY FOR YOU. WE WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE FOURTEEN GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
BECOMING WITH L. A. COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. ONE
THIRTY TWO. NINE THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SORRY I MEANT TO
BE COMMENTING ON AB EIGHTY TWO
OH TWO WRONG PLACE. WILL MOVE TO
LINE THIRTY SIX. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MICHELLE ANDREWS I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE DAVIS COLLEGE
DEMOCRATS AND A FORMER STUDENT
ALEXION POLL WORKER- IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY SEVEN.
SANTIAGO RODRIGUEZ LOOK
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
CALLING IN SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I REQUEST BY
SHARE CERTAIN ARE THERE ANY
STUDIES- THE INDICATE WHY ARE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NOT. ENGAGING
BECAUSE THEY ARE VOTER MOTOR NOW
ONCE THEY GET THEIR LICENSES
THEY GET REGISTERED. SO THERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE THAT'S GOING ON
THAT IS CREATING. THIS LACK OF
INTEREST IN PARTICIPATING IN OUR
DEMOCRACY SO I'M KIND OF CURIOUS
WHAT KIND OF STUDIES IN CHEN AND
HOW'S THIS EXPENDITURE OF
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS- GOING
TO HELP THAT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT GETTING REGISTERED
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO HELP GET REGISTERED. IT'S
THE INTEREST LEVEL AND THAT'S
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT. I'D LIKE
YOU TO ADDRESS THANK YOU YES I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NUMBER- I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THAT. IF IT'S IF YOUNG
FOLKS DON'T FEEL LIKE THERE'S A
CONNECTION TO WHAT THEIR VOTE
MEANS ND HOW THEIR VOTE MAKES A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS ELECTION.
THEY HAVE BECOME DISENGAGED
THERE ARE. STUDIES THAT SHOW
THAT IF YOU GET YOUNG PEOPLE
ENGAGED IN VOTING EARLY ON. THAT
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO BE VOTERS.
ON THAT SUBSIDIZING FORWARD ONTO
THE COMMITTEE I KNOW YOUR ERA
ANALYSTS HAS DATA THAT SHOWS AS
WE START TO ENGAGE PEOPLE EARLY
ON STUDENTS STUDENTS AT A YOUNG
AGE. TO BE ABLE TO START VOTING
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO BE
LIFELONG VOTERS SO GETTING THEM
EARLY ON IN THE PROCESS WILL
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN FOR
THEM BECOME LIFELONG FOR VOTERS
AND WILL INCREASE AT. A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE I THINK THE NUMBER
IS. AND THAT YOU CAN CALL ME IF
I'M WRONG I THINK IT'S LIKE 40%
INCREASE IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS
TO RECALL THAT. THE FIGURE THAT-
BUT WE CAN GET THAT TO YOU SO
YES THE THURSDAY THAT SHOWS IF
YOU START EARLY ON THAT WE GET
THESE AND VOTERS ENGAGE THEY
WILL START TO VOTE AND VOTE ON
AN ONGOING BASIS WITH A FORD.
A SO IT'S SOMETHING BEYOND JUST
GETTING REGISTERED IN THIS
PROGRAM SEEMS TO BE FOCUSED
AROUND THAT REGISTRATION ARE
THERE ADDITIONAL. PARTS OF THIS
PROGRAM THAT. TO MAKE THIS
OUTREACH SOMETHING IT WILL
ACTUALLY GET THEM ENGAGED
BECAUSE GETTING REGISTERED IS
NOT ENGAGING THEM ANYMORE THAN
VERY TRUE IT WAS FOR SO THE NEXT
STEP AS WELL IN PART OF THIS
PROCESS IS ACTUALLY ALLOWING FOR
DIALOGUE FOR THESE YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS TO TALK TO ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO UNDERSTAND. PART OF
WITH THE DATA WILL SHOW IS THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE- DON'T AND VOTERS
IN GENERAL BUT ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE THEY DON'T FOCUS MUCH. ON
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION CYCLES
SO OUR EFFORT HERE THAT WE'RE
PLANNING ON DOING IS ENGAGING
YOUNG VOTERS SO THAT THEY CAN
START TO LEARN THE IMPORTANCE OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE STATE LEVEL ELECTIONS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE DECISIONS
BEING MADE HERE IMPACT THEM
SIGNIFICANTLY THAT'S WHY THE
DATA SHOWS THAT THE VOTED A
PRESIDENTIAL IT'LL DROP OFF
SIGNIFICANTLY IN NON
PRESIDENTIAL. SO THE EFFORT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TERMS OF
ENGAGING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
DEVELOPING THE CURRICULUM WILL
BE ENGAGING THEM ON THAT LOCAL
LEVEL SO. YOU KNOW LOOK POLITICS
IS LOCAL AND WRITING ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WILL ENGAGE THEM
IN A WAY THAT THEY'VE NEVER BEEN
ENGAGED BEFORE TO HAVE THAT
VOICE. TO ONE OF BOTH AND
PARTICIPATED A HIGHER LEVEL
MOVING FORWARD YEAH. I THINK
CIVICS CLASS. IS ONE OF THE
REQUIRED CLASSES AND IN HIGH
SCHOOL. AND IF WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT DURING CIVICS CLASS. AND
WE'RE MAKING IT. AND YOU KNOW
IT'S JUST IT'S AMAZING YOU JUST
SAID THAT BECAUSE- I HAVE
SENIORS IN MY FAMILY IN HIGH
SCHOOL THAT THEY BARELY GET A
QUARTER OF. A SEMESTER RELATED
TO CIVICS. AND I THINK IT'S A
BIG PIECE THAT WE'RE MISSING AS
WELL- I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE SEEN BY
THESE A PILOT THAT WE'VE DONE
INYO COUNTY THAT GETTING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. INCREASE FROM I
THINK THE FIRST MEAN THEY HAD
WAS THIRTY THE FOLLOWING YEAR
THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS THAT. ATTENDED AND ARE
NOW BEING ACTIVE WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY. ON THE OTHER THING WE
TALK ABOUT THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS YOU KNOW I DON'T I
DIDN'T REALIZE IT AS WELL AS
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
ANYWAY TO ANY FUNDING TO DO
OUTREACH AND COUNTIES. AND SO
THIS IS A WAY TO ALSO IS TO HELP
FUND DO WE HAVE MORE. OUTREACH.
INTO THOSE COUNTIES THAT ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED. GREAT YOU FOR
HELPING ME TO UNDER. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH THIS THING.
METACENTRIC MISSTEP WAS A CORE
WITH PRESIDENT MR. BRIAN HERE
BRIAN HERE SEYARTO SEYARTO HERE
BENNETT'S. AND IT HERE LOW MAYES
MAYES HERE MULLIN MULLIN HERE
BLANCA RUBIO. WE HAVE A QUORUM
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS. SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS DECEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I SIMPLY- ELSEVIER I.
BOATS AND WOULD APPRECIATE MAKE
SURE WE GET MORE PEOPLE OUT
THERE REGISTER TO VOTE AND
REALIZE THIS CIVIC DUTY THAT
THEY HAVE YOU GET ONE VOTE EVERY
PERSON GETS ONE. WRONG LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD THAT. THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE BILL A VERY TIMELY
BILL AS ONE OF THE BODIES.
REGISTERED YOUNG PEOPLE- I KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
IT HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR MADAM SECRETARY
CAN CALL THE ROLL EYES THEIR
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. SO
MOVED. MOTION BY MISTER BENNETT
SECONDED BY MR MULLIN. AND
SECRETARY CAN CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BRIAN. BRIAN I SEYARTO NO
SEYARTO NO BANNON HI BENNETT HI
LOW. MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO. THE BILL
IS OUT FOR TO BELIEVE THE ROLE
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FORTY
ONE. AFFORD ONE I'M SORRY THAT'S
OKAY FOR ONE. I. THEN THAT'S ALL
RIGHT THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA IS A. B. SIXTEEN NINETEEN
BY A SEXUAL- THAT'S ON CONSENT
THAT'S EVEN BETTER. AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY TWO BY SOMETHING
NUMBER CERVANTES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AS LAID OUT
ON PAGE FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ALSO WANNA THINK YOU'RE
COMMITTEE STOCK FOR THEIR
DILIGENT ASSISTANCE ON THIS
BILL. THE PURPOSE OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO IS
TO MODERNIZE THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR TO REFLECT THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY REALITIES SINCE THE
ENACTMENT OF THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR ELECTED OFFICIALS AND OTHER
ENTITIES HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO
FILE CAMPAIGN STATEMENTS IN
OTHER REPORTS REGARDING CAMPAIGN
FINANCES. UNDER CURRENT LAW
CAMPAIGN STATEMENTS THAT ARE
FILED ELECTRONICALLY ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO BE FILED PHYSICALLY
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE THE
REALITIES OF THE ONGOING COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAVE RAPIDLY
INCREASED THE VOLUME I REQUEST
FOR ONLINE AND ELECTRONIC FILING
OPTIONS AS MORE AND MORE
BUSINESSES TRANSITION TO ONLINE
ELECTRONIC PROCESSES. FOUR
CAMPAIGN FILINGS SUBMITTED
ELECTRONICALLY AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO AIMS TO ADDRESS THIS
NEW EMPLOYEE OF ELECTRONIC
REQUEST Y ELIMINATING THE
REQUIREMENT OF SUBMITTING A
DUPLICATE PAPER FILING SO LONG
AS THE ELECTRONIC FILINGS ARE
SIGNED WITH AN ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURE AND MEET OTHER
REQUIREMENTS. I UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME STAKEHOLDERS HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THIS BILL WOULD WORK
WITH THE EXISTING CAL ACCESS
SYSTEM. ALL OUR SPONSORS AND I
ARE GOING TO HAVE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS ON FUTURE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION MANAGEABLE FOR CAL
OXIS AND OUR SECRETARY OF STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS LINDSEY O'CONNOR
WITH THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SHE
FROM. MODERATOR BRIAN NUMBER MY
NAME IS. YOU'RE GOOD I'M SORRY
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MY NAME IS LINDA MCCONNELL I'M
SENIOR LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL IT'S
A FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION
APPROVED THE FANFARE AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES. UNDER EXISTING
LAW THE POLITICAL PHARMACOPHORE
CERTAIN STATEMENTS AND REPORTS
TO BE FILED WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE IN PAPER
FORMAT. AND ELECTRONICALLY
THROUGH CAL ACCESS. SEVERAL
YEARS THE PAST THREE YEARS
ESPECIALLY WE HAVE SEEN BUSINESS
INCREASINGLY MOVE ONLINE
INTERNAL PROCESSES. AND
ACCORDINGLY WE GOT INCREASE THE
QUEST FOR PURELY ELECTRONIC
FILING OPTIONS. THE GOAL THE
FILTER AT LEAST SOME OF THE
BURDEN OF DUPLICATE PAPER FILING
AND THE NEED TO GATHER HUNDRED
SIGNATURES FOR THE FILING. THE
COMMISSION UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE SOME LIMITATIONS GIVEN THE
CURRENT ELECTRONIC FILING
SYSTEM. AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
AND THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE TO
IDENTIFY THE LIMITATIONS IN
DETAIL TO ENSURE THAT ANY
ELIMINATION OF PAPER FILINGS
DOES NOT RESULT IN ANY REDUCTION
TO DISCLOSURE OR TRANSPARENCY.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CHANGES WILL WORK BUT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S CURRENT
SYSTEM. THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
SERVICE FAIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE
CONSIDER THE BILL I RESPECT ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO WE HAVE
A PRIMARY IN OPPOSITION. THAT'S
GOOD. WHEN I MOVED TO A DID NOT
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AS A
REMINDER TO THE PUBLIC LEVEL
MAXIMUM FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL
TIME FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL THIS NO WITNESSES
ARE LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENTED ANY POSITION ON THE
BILL WE WILL START WITH PEOPLE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES. TO
PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON THIS
BILL. YES GOOD MORNING- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TED MAUL
HAUSER ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY OF
STATE- SURELY AND WEBER PHD.
WELL THE SECRETARY OF STATE DOES
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL-
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES THAT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. OF WOULD
BE- SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS AND
I THINK THE AUTHOR TODAY HAVE
ALSO MENTIONED STAKEHOLDERS-
MONEY BE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO
AND WE- LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND ALL THOSE
OTHERS- TO FURTHER THE GOALS OF
THE BILL- CHAIR BRIAN WE DO-
LIKE I SAID AGREE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION- OF THE-
COMMITTEE. AND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE IS 1100% BEHIND
THE GOALS OF MOVING TOWARD.
ELECTRONIC FILING. OF CAMPAIGN
AND LOBBYING STATEMENTS. AND
IMPROVING PUBLIC ACCESS TO THAT
DATA. WE WANT AS MUCH DISCLOSURE
AS POSSIBLE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE-
AS MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S. OFFICE
DOES HAVE REAL SYSTEM A SYSTEM
LIMITATIONS- THE THIS RELATES TO
THE FORMER WHICH INITIAL FILINGS
ARE PRESENTED TO OUR OFFICE AND
THE SECURITY OF ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURES- THAT WOULD BE
ATTACHED ONLINE FILINGS. IT WILL
BE PART OF THE OVERALL THIS.
THAT HAVE WITH THE AND SMALL OF
A TWENTY WITH. TWO GOING
FORWARD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE OF THE CRAFT A PROPOSAL
THAT PROVIDES THE MOST SECURE
AND- EFFICIENT DISCLOSURES AS
POSSIBLE WITHIN CURRENT
RESOURCES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM WHO WISH TO SPEAK ON
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO.
MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
LINE WHICH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO. MEMBERS BEACON
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
LOCATED UP AND ON THE PHONE
MUCH. WE WILL NOW GO TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- WHO WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL. I'M OF THE
BILL. THANK. THANK YOU AS WE
INCREASINGLY RELY ON ELECTRONIC
TRANSACTIONS FOR ALL OF OUR DAY
TO DAY TASKS THAT THE GOALS OF
THIS BILL- ARE UNDERSTANDABLE
AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONABLE STEPS WE CAN TAKE FOR
YOUR REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON
PAPER I DO SHARE SIMILAR
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW IT RELATES TO
THE CURRENT CAL ACCESS SYSTEM-
BUT I AM CONFIDENT- WITH THE
SPONSORS REMARKS AND WITH THE
OFFICE MARKS THAT THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE WORKED OUT WITH
THE SECTOR STATES OFFICE AND
OTHERS AND SO THIS. BILL DOES
HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
MADAM SECRETARY COMING CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BRIAN. BRIAN I SEYARTO. SEYARTO
HI BANANTS. LOW MAYES MAYES AYE
MULLIN MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO.
IT'S ALFA FOUR ZERO DOUBLES UP
FOUR ZERO THANK YOU MR MEMBERS.
YES AT THIS TIME WITH A QUORUM
PRESENT CAN WE TAKE OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW I'M OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE'S ONE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE BILL IS
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SIXTEEN
NINETEEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
CERVANTES S PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED AS SPECIFIED IN COMMON
NUMBER FIVE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. THAT OF SECRETARY CAN
CALL THE ROLL. THE FACT. FOR
MOTIONS TO PASS IS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BRIAN HI. BRIAN I
SEYARTO. SEYARTO IDENTIT. LOW
LEVEL I MAYES. MAYES AYE MULLIN
. MULLIN I BLOCK RUBIO. ITSELF
THANK YOU SO WE ARE GOING TO
JUMP- OUT OF FILE ORDER TODAY
FOR A SPECIAL MEMBER OF THIS
BODY IN THIS COMMITTEE THE NEXT
ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS AB TWENTY
SIX OH EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY THANK YOU
CHAIR BRIAN AND IT IT'S GREAT TO
BE BACK BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
THERE'S DEFINITELY STILL FEELS
LIKE HOME I'M GLAD THAT THE
COMMITTEE FINALLY GOT THE HIGH
QUALITY LEADERSHIP IT DESERVES-
BUT I APOLOGIZE THAT THE
MEMBERS. IMPROVED I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS BILL AND FOR THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS. WHICH
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE AS WELL AS AN
URGENCY CLAUSE PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
I'D ALSO BE REMISS NOT TO THINK
THE COMMITTEE'S PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT. AS WELL FOR HER WORK
LAST YEAR ON VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS WHICH IS WHY I'M BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY. FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL ELECTION
IN THE MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC MY
AB EIGHT SIXTY REQUIRE THAT
ELECTION OFFICIALS SENT A VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOT TO EVERY ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTER. CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS WERE ABLE TO
CONDUCT A SAFE AND SECURE
ELECTION THAT ALSO SAW
HISTORICALLY HIGH TURNOUT. LAST
YEAR BUILDING UPON THE SUCCESS
OF TWENTY TWENTY I WAS PROUD TO
AUTHOR AB THIRTY SEVEN TO
REQUIRE ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
SEND A VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT TO
EVERY ACTIVE REGISTERED VOTER.
FOR ALL FUTURE ELECTIONS IN
WHICH THE VOTER IS ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE. IN RECOGNITION OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE BROUGHT ABOUT
BY MY PRIOR LEGISLATION AB
TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY SIX OH
EIGHT WOULD MAKE NUMEROUS VOTE
BY MAIL RELATED CONFORMING
CHANGES TO THE ELECTIONS CODE.
INCLUDING REPEALING A NUMBER OF
OBSOLETE PROVISIONS AND UPDATING
NUMEROUS OTHERS TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY IN OUR LAWS RELATED
TO VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR FOR AN
AYE VOTE- AND WITH ME TODAY
TESTIFYING AS AIR GARRIS. DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF STATE FOR
LEGISLATIVE AND CONSTITUENT
AFFAIRS. ON BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE WEBER. AND ROBBY
ANDERSON STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
SECRETARY OF STATE'S ELECTION
DIVISION AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
MISTER GARRISON MISTER ANDERSON
ARE BOTH ON THE PHONE LINES- IN
PERSON TODAY HERE TODAY WHAT.
THE NEW WORLD. WAR MAYBE THANK
YOU A GOOD MORNING MISTER
MEMBERS ERIC- SOME HAVE
SECRETARY STATE DR SHIRLEY WEBER
SPONSORED ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX AWAIT LET ME START BY
THANKING SOME OF OUR BERMAN IS A
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE ON A B. TWENTY
SIX AWAIT A SIMPLE CLEAN UP
MEASURE THAT MAKES CONSISTENT
THE PROVISIONS OF THE ELECTION
CODE REGARDING VOTE BY MAIL
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES.
SUBSEQUENT TO THE PASSAGE OF A
BEAST ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVEN
WHICH WENT INTO EFFECT EARLIER
THIS YEAR CERTAIN PROVISIONS OF
THE ELECTIONS GO TO BECOME A
RELEVANT ARE CONTRADICTORY TO
THE PROVISIONS OF THE CODE THERE
FOR AB TWENTY SIX AWAIT IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS NO INCONSISTENCY AMONG THE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO THE BOOK
BUT NO PROCESS. NOW THAT THE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES EVERY READ
ELIGIBLE REGISTERED VOTERS
RECEIVE VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT AB
TWENTY SIX AWAIT SERVES TO
MINIMIZE ANY POSSIBLE CONFUSION
FROM BOOK CONFUSION FOR VOTERS
AGAIN ONLINE TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ROBBY
ANDERSON STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND
SECRETARY. STATE URGED
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIGHT.
THANK YOU MYSTERIOUS. PASSING
PRIME WITNESSES OPPOSITION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ADDITIONAL-
PUBLIC COMMENT- HAS REMINDER
FIFTEEN MINUTES TOTAL TIME PER
BILL. NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
ON THE BILL WILL START. WITH
MEMBERS IN THE ROOM IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WISHES TO SPEAK ON AB TWENTY SIX
AWAIT. SEEING NONE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE WAS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT AB TWENTY
SIX AWAY. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE NO INCLUDING A PARDON ME
WE HAVE SOMEONE QUEUING UP ON
THE PHONE LINES ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WE WILL OPEN UP LINE FIFTY SIX
pTHIS IS TRICIA WEBER. CO CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLEAR COMPLEXION OFFICIALS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE IN WEREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX AWAIT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
COULD UP AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR IN ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THE
BILL. SEEING NONE I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THE AUTHOR IS GOING
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES.
AMENDMENTS ABSOLUTELY THE-
PREVIOUSLY MEMINTA HAPPENED
EXCEPT ON IRAN I WANT TO APPLAUD
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. FIRST FOR AUTHORING
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR TO MAKE
SURE. FOLKS COULD NOT SAFELY IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND THEN FOR AB
THIRTY SEVEN. WHICH DID VOTE BY
MAIL FOR EVERY ELIGIBLE VOTER-
I'M RECOMMENDING A STRONG
SUPPORT. WITHIN MINUTES
OUTLINED. MADAM SECRETARY
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
HOW DID WE HAVE A SECOND. THING
THANK YOU MISTER MOM. TOUGH
CROWD. MEMBERSHIP IS BOGUS YEAH
EXACTLY. IF THAT AFFECTED OTHER
OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS
INCLUDING AMENDMENTS TO ADDED
URGENCY CLAUSE AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BRIAN HI BRIAN I SEYARTO SEYARTO
NO BENEFITS BENNETT HI LOW. WELL
I MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN. MULLIN
I BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I.
THAT BILLS OUT SIX TO ONE MR
BERMAN YOU LOOK COMFORTABLE A
SUSPECTED REASON IS BECAUSE THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS AB.
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTEEN BY SOMEONE
NUMBER BERMAN. THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES OF FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. DESCRIBED
IN THE ANALYSIS HELLO. WELL
VOTING HAS BECOME MORE
ACCESSIBLE LOW TURNOUT AMONG
YOUNG VOTERS IS STILL PREVALENT.
VOTERS AGE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FOUR REMAIN THE MOST
UNDERREPRESENTED AGE GROUP AMONG
CALIFORNIA'S VOTING ELECTORATE.
TO ADDRESS THIS ONGOING PROBLEM
OF LOW VOTING TURNOUT AB TWENTY
FIFTEEN WOULD MAKE IT MORE
CONVENIENT FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS.
TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE.
BY REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND REQUESTING
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THE PLACE A VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
DROP BOX LOCATION ON EVERY
CAMPUS. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO GIVE PREFERENCE TO
PLACING A VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
DROP BOX LOCATION ON CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE AN ANNUAL ENROLLMENT OF AT
LEAST TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS.
THIS BILL BUILDS UPON EXISTING
PRACTICE BY SOME CSU AND UC
CAMPUSES THAT ALREADY PROVIDE
BALLOT DROP BOX LOCATIONS. AND
WOULD ENSURE GREATER GREATER
VOTING X. ACCESSIBILITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTEEN AND
WITH ME TODAY IS ALEX NILES.
REPRESENTING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION NOW
WE'VE GOT. THANK YOU CHAIR BRIAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS ALICE STYLES AND I SERVE
AS THE CHAIR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SINICIZATION. I'M
ALSO A STUDENT AT UC SANTA
BARBARA. AND I COME BEFORE YOU
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON
THIS BILL AS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO IMPROVE THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF VOTING. FOR
STUDENTS ON CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. AT THE YOU SEE
THIS BILL WOULD REQUEST THAT
EACH CAMPUS ENSURE THERE'S AT
LEAST ONE BALLOT DROP BOX
LOCATIONS HER CAMPUS. CURRENTLY
FOUR OUT OF TEN UC CAMPUSES DO
NOT HAVE ONE. YOU SEE STUDENTS
CARE ABOUT VOTING AND AS A
COMMUNITY WE WORK HARD TO
PROMOTE PARTICIPATION IN
ELECTIONS. WE ARE NOT APATHETIC.
EACH ELECTION CYCLE YOU SEE SOON
ORGANIZER'S REGISTER THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS TO VOTE. MANY FOR
THE FIRST TIME. ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE UCSF WORK DIRECTLY AND
CONSTANTLY WITH THE STATE AND
THE UC ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP
PRACTICES THAT IMPROVE SOON
TURNED OUT. STUDENT GROUPS SPEND
COUNTLESS HOURS TRYING TO GET
OTHER NATIONS TO VOTE AHEAD OF
ELECTIONS IN A BALLOT DROP BOX
TO BE JUST ANOTHER TOOL FOR US
TO UTILIZE WHEN ENCOURAGING
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. AND VOTER
PARTICIPATION AMONG OUR PEERS.
SINCE I'VE ALSO BEEN ONE OF THE
MAIN FORCES IN GETTING THE
BALLOT DROP BOXES ALREADY EXIST.
THESE BOXES ARE JUST WOMAN WOULD
REMOVE BARRIERS AND GIVE MORE
SINCE THE VOTE. I CAMPUSES
ALREADY HAVE THEM DROP BOXES ARE
BEING INSTALLED IN SOME OF THE
MOST ACCESSIBLE CENTRAL
LOCATIONS. AND I'VE BEEN GETTING
HEAVY USE. THESE BOXES ALSO OF A
REAL BENEFITS THE ELECTORAL
CULTURE ON CAMPUS THERE ARE
REMINDERS TO GO VOTE. AND I
GUARANTEE YOU THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO SHOW UP IN INSTAGRAM AND TAKE
TALK POSED. BY XIN ORGANIZER'S
AHEAD OF ELECTIONS DOING
OUTREACH EFFORTS. ENSURING THE
AVAILABILITY OF ON CAMPUS DROP
BOXES WILL BE AN IMPORTANT PART
OF MAKING VOTING MORE ACCESSIBLE
AMONG YOUNG VOTERS. HELLO
EFFECTIVELY INCREASE IN TURN
OUT. WILL MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THE FAST
EFFICIENT VOTING EXPERIENCE
EVERYONE DESERVES. IF THE
LEGISLATURE MAKES IS AVAILABLE
YOU CAN REST ASSURED THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES WILL TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THEM. THANK YOU. GO
OUT TO US. COBRAS THAT IS AWARE
GOAL YOU SEE SCHOOLS OF ALL
TYPES. C. N. NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WILL NOW
TURN INTO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT STARTING WITH MEMBERS
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM
WHERE THE MEMBERS IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM AND WISH TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL. FOR MINOR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL. NHL OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU MISTER. ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM SAYING NONE WE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY-
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES
WISHING TO SPEAK ON AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTEEN. TO SPEAK ON THIS
MEASURE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE NEED TO HAVE SOMEONE
COMING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE THE
PROVIDER LINE NUMBER
. FOR
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANK WE WILL
OPEN LINE FIFTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ISN'T GOING CAMP JUNIOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
TIRED AMERICANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MISTER SHERMAN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANYBODY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR ON THIS BILL. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. SALUTE AND THE
SECOND MOVE BY MR BENNETT
SECONDED BY MISS RUBIO. IT'S
GREAT BILL HAS SUPPORT OF THE
CHAIR I'M RECOMMENDING A DO PASS
THAT OF SECRETARY CAN CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOST IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BRIAN. RYAN I SEYARTO. C. R. TWO
IS NOT VOTING. BENNETT BENNETT I
LOW FLOW I MAYES MAYES MULLIN
MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO I. SIX YEAR OF THE BILLS
OUT FIGURE BUT A GOOD DEAL TO
FOR TO MR BERMAN WADA. THE NEXT
ITEM ON THE AGENDA AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FOUR MISTER SALAS.
WELCOME. YOU CAN SEE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. GO BRUINS US
THE. THANK YOU RICHARD THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MAY THAT IMPROV TO
PRESENT BILL TWENTY NINETY FOUR
SIMPLE BILL THAT CREATES AN
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION FOR KERN COUNTY
MODELED AFTER THE STATE
COMMISSION THAT CALIFORNIA
VOTERS APPROVED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. THE INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION WILL BE MADE UP OF
REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS AND
DECLINE TO STATE VOTERS WHO LIVE
IN KERN COUNTY- THIS IS BETTY
COMMISSION WILL PROTECT
TAXPAYERS FROM HAVING THEIR HARD
EARNED DOLLARS WASTED ON
LAWSUITS LIKE THE ONE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE'RE KERN COUNTY WAS
SUED FOR NOT HAVING FAIR
POLITICAL MAPS. THE INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN OTHER
COUNTIES LIKE LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO SANTA BARBARA AND SAN
FRANCISCO. AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
FOUR IS A CONTINUATION OF THE
STATE'S WORK TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH AND INTEGRITY OF OUR
DEMOCRACY. AND PROTECT
EVERYONE'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO AN EQUAL VOTE. I WITH ME TO
TESTIFIED BY PHONE TODAY IS
LAURIE PRASANTH AND DOOR SUPPORT
THE FROM THEDOOR SUPPORT THE
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU MRS
SELLERS WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF
THIS BILL. AS A REMINDER EACH
WITNESS HAS A MAXIMUM OF TWO
MINUTES. MODERATOR CAN WE OPEN
THE LINE. FOR LOWER PERCENT IN
DELORES HUERTA. IF THEY'VE
DIALED IN THEIR LINE SHOULD BE
OPEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS
WEEKEND. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAURIE TO
FONTAINE AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT FORTY
DEVOTED SUPPORT THE FOUNDATION
OUR PROFOUND THANKS TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR I RAN
THE FOUNDATION TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REDISTRICTING CAMPAIGN AND WE
COLLECTED THOUSANDS OF COMMUNITY
OF INTEREST SURVEYS AT FLEA
MARKETS COVERT OUTREACH EVENTS
FOOD BANKS THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN HIGH DESERT.
WE INVITED EVERYONE WHO TOK A
SURVEY TO LEARN ABOUT
REDISTRICTING AND WE HELD
MULTIPLE MAPPING SESSION EACH
WEEK FOR OVER A YEAR IT GAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT EVERY HEARING
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ULTIMATELY WE EMPOWERED OVER
FIVE THOUSAND RESIDENTS TO
ENGAGE IN REDISTRICTING PROCESS
THESE AT ALL LEVELS OF THEIR
GOVERNMENT THESE GRASSROOTS
VOLUNTEERS AND ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BECOME COLLECTIVELY KNOWN.
AS THE EQUITABLE MAPS COALITION.
BUT EVEN WITH THE BONDS. LEVELS
OF AUTHENTIC COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION IT WAS EXTREMELY
RARE TO SEE FAIR MAPS ADOPTED ATTHE LOCAL LEVEL ANYWHERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND ESPECIALLY IN
KERN COUNTY. IT IS NO
COINCIDENCE THAT THE BEST MAPS
WE SAW ADOPTED FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE'RE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
BECAUSE OF THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. AND
WITHOUT A CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION AND KERN COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS DID WHAT THEY
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE DONE MANY
MANY TIMES IN THE PAST. THEY
PAID HUGE AMOUNTS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO ATTORNEYS AND
DEMOGRAPHER'S TO DRAW THE MAPS
THAT CONCENTRATE POWER IN THE
HANDS OF WHITE AFFLUENT CURRENT
RESIDENTS. TO THE PROFOUND
DETRIMENT OF CURRENT RURAL AND
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS AND
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE OF COLOR THEY
HAVE BACK BEEN FOUND BY THE
COURTS TWICE TO HAVE
DISENFRANCHISED LATINO. THE
IMPACT OF THIS BE OVER. KERN
COUNTY HAS NEVER DRAWN OF VOTING
RIGHTS ACT DISTRICT WITHOUT
BEING LEGALLY COMPELLED TO DO SO
COSTING TAXPAYERS MILLIONS. AND
THE OF THE LACK OF COMMUNITY
RESPONSES CALCULABLE LEADERSHIP
HAD KERN COUNTY FAILING BY EVERY
QUALITY OF LIFE INDICATOR IT IS
POSSIBLE THE MEASURE AND THE
PANDEMIC WE ALL KNOW THAT THIS
MEANS PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES. I WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR
BECAUSE WE ARE COMMITTED TO
HELPING DEMOCRATIC PROPHECIES
AND LOCAL CITIZEN CONTROL OF
CURRENT REDISTRICTING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMTTEE
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISBEHAVE MISS WORKED ON THE
LINE. I DON'T SHOWED OBVIOUS
WHERE TO HAVING DIALED IT HAS A
SPEAKER. KRESNA WITNESS RATHER
THANK YOU SHE DOES ALLEN PLEASE
LET US KNOW- WE ALWAYS HAVE TIME
FOR THE LOSS WITH THE- SEEING NO
PRIMARY. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
REMINDER NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL. MORNING
DOOR ROSALIE FOR IN VOTERS ARE
CALIFORNIA AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL THANK YOU MISS ROSE
SCENTED BODY ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. MISTER MODERATOR
WILL NOW MOVE BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR NATIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WE'LLGO TO LINE FIFTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS- THE MORNING CARE
MEMBERS AND- CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M SORRY MY NAME IS TAMMY TYLER
AND I LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE A FAIR
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBERS.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
IN THE BURKE MY NAME IS THE YEAH
THAT'LL AND I LIVE IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTEEN. HI THIS IS
THE LOWEST ONE THAT EMPHASIZED
THAT THE SOMEONE I WAS THE NAKED%
BEFORE BUT IF YOU DON'T GET A
LOT OF WORK ON THE SENSOR- SO
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE OF
THE TO THE TYPE OF THE
REPRESENTATION AND COLLECTIVELY
THE THAT THAT THE PEN OUT IN
TERMS OF THE STATE'S IN THE
CONGRESSIONAL SEAT WITH ALL THE
WORK TO BE DONE ON THE
REDISTRICTING THAT MR. LLOYD
PRASANTA JUST MENTIONED- BUT WE
DO KNOW THAT WE NEED BETTER
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE ALL OF
THE RESOURCES THAT THE GRANDKIDS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND AT THE
STATE LEVEL THEY HAVE TO GO TO
THE BUDGET SUPERVISORS AND
SOMETIMES WE DO NOT SEE THAT
THOSE PLEASE PUT THE. VACUUM ARE
REALLY A GIVEN TO THE PEOPLE
THAT. NEED IT THE OF. THIS THE
PEOPLE PORT. BECAUSE THE DEFENSE
OF THE BOARD TO PROVIDE HIS MAKE
. REALLY AFFECT THE- OF OUR LOW
INCOME. ITSELF AMONG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE TICKET OF THE
MEASURE. ONE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS. PLAYER
REPRESENTATIVES INTO DIFFERENT I
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU AT THE
MEDICAL THANK YOU MUCH. AT THE
LOWEST POINT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BYE THE. LINE SIXTY THREE.
ONE SIXTY ALLY IS OPEN AHEAD
PLEASE- HELLO YES HI MY NAME
HARM I AM WITH LET'S CAL. MOST
OF THE MAYOR AND LUIS. AND I AM
IN SUPPORT AS A. TWO FOUR FOUR.
LINE FIFTY NINE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THOMAS
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR. LINE. SIXTY FIVE.
GREETINGS CHAIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TODD SCHUMAN
I LIVE IN HATCH P. WHICH IS IN
KERN COUNTY IN THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CHAIR OF THE CURRENT
GOAL WE- CHAPTER OF THE SIERRA
CLUB- AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING
OUR- TWELVE HUNDRED MEMBERS IN
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
SIERRA CLUB IS STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR NINE
FOUR. NINE FIFTY FIVE. MANY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GARCIA AND I
AM THE PRIMARY BE MAPPED TRAWLER
WITH THE EQUITABLE MAPS
COALITION ARE WORKING WITH
LAURIE WE SAW FIRST HAND THERE
IS THE SENSE OF- STATUS QUO
POLITICIANS TO PARAGRAPHS AND SO
ON STRONG SUPPORT OF THE RESULT
OF THE BILL. TWENTY NINE TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY NINETY. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AMANDA
HONEY CUT AND I AM CALLING AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR NINETY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF THE LOTUS WHAT THE
FOUNDATION AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
A KERN COUNTY RESIDENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU LINE
FIFTY ONE. ONE OF THE AS GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SONNY BONO AND CO DIRECTOR OF
LEFT FOR TOMORROW AND I LIVE IN
UNINCORPORATED KERN COUNTY
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF OUR ORGANIZATION THANK
YOU HAVE A GOOD ONE. NINE FORTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LISA WORKS FINE AND
I'VE BEEN A RESIDENT KERN COUNTY
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS AND AFTER
WITNESSING MANY TIMES TESTIMONY-
BEFORE THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. UHHUH TEST. ARE TAKING INTO.
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT SB TWO
FOUR NINE FOUR AND I AM ALSO AN
EMPLOYEE OF AT A LOSS WITH THE
FOUNDATION I THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL NOW TAKE IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF ANY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE. WITH
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
REGARDING AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
FOUR. MOST OF THE BILL MUST
ALLOW. SECONDED BY MISS RUBIO.
SINGLE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MADAM SECRETARY CAN CALDERON.
ALL THIS HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
CHAIR THANK YOU THE MOTION IS DO
YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BRIAN HI BRIAN I SEYARTO SEYARTO
NO BANANTS. YES BECAUSE BANAT I
LOW WELL I MAYES MAYES MULLIN
MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO I WANT
RUBIO I. THANK YOU MR ABOUT
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU SALAS. THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT BY SOME
MEMBER O'DONNELL SOME MEMBER
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. YOU MAY
PRESENT WILL MAY PROCEED IN
REDDING YES SIR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWO EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
WHICH WOULD BAN RANK CHOICE
VOTING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO START BY
SAYING I COME AT THIS ISSUE AS A
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER AND SOMEONE
WHO HAS WON SEVEN OR SO
ELECTIONS EVEN A RIGHT AND
ALEXION AND AS ONE WHO IS VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF DEMOCRACY IN A
LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH IT AND
I CONSIDER MYSELF. A DEFENDER OF
THE AMERICAN ELECTORAL PROCESS.
AND AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER I'M A
PROMOTER OF DEMOCRACY AND
ACTUALLY TEACH STUDENTS HOW TO
VOTE FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME AS
A HIGH SCHOOL GOVERNMENT
TEACHER. SOMETHING I'LL BE DOING
THIS FALL. TO ME THIS BILL IS
ABOUT PROTECTING DEMOCRACY AND
MAKING SURE ALL CAN PARTICIPATE
IN IT AND PROTECTING MAJORITY
RULE. SOMETHING MUCH AMERICAN
BLOOD HAS BEEN SHED TO DO. I AM
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT THE CONCEPT OF ONE
PERSON ONE VOTE. AND NOT CHANGE
THE WAY WE VOTE SIMPLY BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T LIKE THE OUTCOME. OF
THE LAST ELECTION. AS ONE WHO
HAS TAUGHT STUDENTS ABOUT THE
VALUE OF OUR DEMOCRACY AND
NAVIGATED ITS NUANCES FIRSTHAND.
I RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
HOW WE OPERATE THAT DEMOCRACY.
AND I BELIEVE I HAVE THE SAME
GOALS ALL OF YOU ON THIS
COMMITTEE YOU MISTER CHAIR WHICH
IS TO ENSURE OUR ELECTIONS
CORRECTLY REFLECT. THE WILL OF
OUR PEOPLE AND I'M CONFIDENT THE
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL DUE TO.
THIS MEANS WE SHOULD BE PRUDENT
IN EVALUATING PROPOSED REFORMS
AND NOT SACRIFICE FUNDAMENTAL
ACTS ASPECTS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
IN AN EFFORT TO SOLVE PRACTICAL
ISSUES WITH OUR ELECTIONS. AGAIN
WE SHOULD AVOID FADS LIKE TERM
LIMITS AND RANKED CHOICE VOTING
. AND RANK CHOICE VOTING IS NOW
SPREADING IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR
NUMBER YEARS IT'S REALLY
SPREADING NOW ONE OF EFFORTS
JUST. TO REALLY PUT THE GAS ON.
ANY TIME WE CREATE A MECHANISM
AND A DEMOCRACY. TO DO THE DUTY
THAT WHICH IS THE PEOPLE'S IT
FAILS. NOW SAY THAT AGAIN.
ANYTIME WE CREATE AMERICA AND A
MECHANISM IN A DEMOCRACY TO DO
THE DUTY THAT WHICH IS THE
PEOPLE'S. IT FAILS. TERM LIMITS
ARE A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THAT. HAS
LIMITING THOSE WHO CAN BE
ELECTED BEEN THE GREAT FIX
EVERYBODY IS SEEKING I THANK NOT
. AND WHAT IS THAT GREAT FIX.
MAINLY IT'S IN THE EYE OF THE
BEHOLDER BUT NOT NECESSARILY
BEHOLDEN TO THE BASIC TENETS OF
DEMOCRACY. IN SHORT OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS NEVER CONTEMPLATED THAT
WE WOULD CONJURE UP A SHORT CUT
IN ORDER TO BETTER OUR
DEMOCRACY. BUT HERE WE ARE
DISCUSSING RANKED CHOICE VOTING
WHICH I'M ARGUING TODAY IS A
SHORT CUT AND CHEAPENS THE MOCK
CHRISSY AND THE EFFORTS OF THOSE
WHO HAVE SOUGHT TO PROTECTED
AROUND THE GLOBE. FIRST WHAT IS
RANKED CHOICE VOTING. WELL IT'S
HARD TO EXPLAIN SO THERE'S THE
FIRST PROBLEM. IT IS DIFFERENT
THAN A STANDARD ELECTION WHEREIN
THE ONE WHO GETS THE MOST VOTES
WINS OR MOVES ON TO A RUNOFF.
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT. AS YOU MAY
BE AWARE RANKED CHOICE VOTING IS
THE PROCESS WHEREIN VOTERS ARE
ASKED TO RANK THEIR CANDIDATES
IN ORDER OF PREFERENCE. INSTEAD
OF VOTING FOR A SINGLE CANDIDATE
AND ALLOWING THE CANDIDATE GETS
THE MOST VOTES TO BE THE VICTOR.
OR TO GO WORK TO GO FOR TO A
RUNOFF. WITH RANKED CHOICE
VOTING SHOULD NO CANDIDATE
ACHIEVE A MATE MAJORITY VOTE THE
LOWEST VOTE EARNING CANDIDATE.
IS ELIMINATED AND THE VOTERS
NEXT PREFERRED CANDIDATE IS
COUNTED INSTEAD. THE PROCESS
CONTINUES AND ROUNDS. AND IT
REPEATS UNTIL A CANDIDATE HAS A
MAJORITY OF VOTES IN THE
ELECTION. THERE COULD BE MANY
ROOM THERE COULD BE MANY ROUNDS
OF VOTERS MAY VOTE MANY TIMES
FOR JUST AN OFFICE. SO AGAIN
RANK CHOICE VOTING REQUIRES
VOTERS TO RANK CANDIDATES IN
ORDER OF PREFERENCE OF NOBLE IF
NO CANDIDATE IN ROUND ONE
RECEIVES 50% OF THE FIRST PLACE
VOTES THE ONE RECEIVING THE
FEWEST VOTES IS ELIMINATED. AND
THAT CONTENDERS SECOND PLACE
VOTES ARE ALLOCATED TO THE
REMAINING CANDIDATES. THESE RE
OUT THESE ROUNDS REALLOCATING
SECOND THIRD OR FOURTH PLACE
VOTES OR MORE FROM THE BOTTOM UP
CONTINUE. UNTIL ONE CANDIDATE.
GETS A MAJORITY CONFUSED. YOU
SHOULD BE BECAUSE SORT OF VOTERS
. IN ESSENCE IT IS ONE PERSON
MANY VOTES NOT ONE PERSON ONE
VOTE. BUT WHY SUPPORT RANKED
CHOICE VOTING AND I MET WITH
SOME OF THE SUPPORTERS NO LAW
ALL SUPPORTERS BUT THESE ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS I HEARD- AND
WHY THEY SUPPORTED RANKED CHOICE
VOTING. IT SAVES MONEY BECAUSE
THERE WILL ONLY BE ONE ELECTION
AND MY RESPONSE TO THAT IS
SIMPLE. WE'RE GOING TO ALTER
DEMOCRACY JUST TO MAKE ELECTIONS
CHEAPER. NOBODY SAID DEMOCRACY
WAS FREE. AND WE CAN AFFORD
ELECTIONS. ANOTHER REASON RANK
CHOICE VOTING IS MORE CONVENIENT
FOR PEOPLE ON THEY WILL NOT HAVE
TO FILL OUT ANOTHER BALLOT IN A
RUN OFF MY RESPONSE TO THAT.
DEMOCRACY IS NOT ALWAYS
CONVENIENT AND WE SHOULD NOT
CHEAP IN THE ELECTORAL PROCESS
JUST TO APPEASE THOSE WHO DON'T
NOT WANT TO BE INCONVENIENCED
WITH VOTING. VOTING IS A CIVIC
DUTY NOT A CIVIC BOTHERED. NEXT
RANK CHOICE VOTING HELPS ME GET
THOSE THAT SUPPORT MY CAUSE IS
MORE EASILY ELECTED ESSENTIALLY
SPECIAL INTERESTS CAN BETTER
CONTROL THE OUTCOME. I BELIEVE
THAT STATEMENT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF
. THEY OFFER MENTION ARGUMENTS
ARE NOT REFLECTIVE OF DEMOCRATIC
VALUES. BUT I'VE CONVENIENCE AND
I FIND THAT UNFORTUNATE. NOW THE
PROBLEMS WITH DRINK CHOICE
VOTING. NUMBER ONE VOTER
CONFUSION HEY ASKING VOTERS TO
RANK THEIR CHOICES INSTEAD OF
CHOOSING A SINGLE CANDIDATE
CONFUSES VOTERS WHO ARE USED TO
THE DEMOCRATIC CONCEPT OF THE
ONE WITH THE MOST VOTES WINS.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THIS DYNAMIC
IMPACTS MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
MOST. ENGLISH LEARNERS AND THOSE
WHO HAVE ACCESS TO MAINSTREAM
MEDIA OR AN EDUCATION CAMPAIGN
MAY BE TAKING PLACE ARE LEFT TO
FIGURE IT OUT FOR THEMSELVES I
GIVE THE EXAMPLE OF THAT FROM MY
OWN LIFE. I TAUGHT ESL FOR MANY
YEARS THAT'S ADULTS RIGHT MANY
HAD LIMITED ENGLISH RIGHT BUT
MANY WERE CITIZENS OR BECOMING
CITIZENS AND I WOULD TEACH THEM
HOW TO VOTE HOW THE PROCESS
WORKS BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE.
TRYING TO TEACH SOME OF THESE
FOLKS WITH LIMITED ENGLISH. HOW
TO VOTE. THE DIRECT CHOICE IT
WOULD BE VERY A VERY COMPLEX
TASK BECAUSE IT'S SO HARD. TO
EXPLAIN. RANKED CHOICE VOTING
DISENFRANCHISES VOTERS MANY
VOTERS GIVE UP AND DON'T FINISH
VOTING AND ALL AROUND BECAUSE OF
VOTER FATIGUE. ONE STUDY SHOWED
THAT ALMOST 30% OF VOTERS GAVE
UP BEFORE COMPLETING ALL OF THE
VOTING ROUNDS BECAUSE OF FATIGUE
CONFUSION. IT CAN BE ARGUED THAT
THIS IS DISENFRANCHISEMENT
MASQUERADING AS A MORE EFFICIENT
DEMOCRACY. MAKE GAMING THE VOTE
THIS IS REAL. THOSE WHO FULLY
UNDERSTAND RANKED CHOICE VOTING
FOLLOW SPECIAL INTERESTS OFFICE
CAN TURN ELECTION INTO SOMETHING
AKIN TO A PREDICTIVE VIDEO GAME.
WHEREIN A GROUP OF VOTERS ARE
LED TO VOTE IN SPECIFIC PATTERNS
SO AS TO ELIMINATE ONE CANDIDATE
AND PROP UP ANOTHER THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT ROUNDS OF VOTING. NEXT
MAJORITY RULE. RANKED CHOICE
VOTING GOES AGAINST THE CONCEPT
OF ONE PERSON ONE VOTE AND
MAJORITY RULE. IF A CANDIDATE
ONLY ACHIEVES A MAJORITY BY
ELIMINATING THOSE THAT IS NOT A
REAL MAJORITY. MAJORITY RULE
WITH MINORITY RIGHTS IS AN
AMERICAN VALUE. TANK NEXT WILL
RANK CHOICE VOTING FIX THE
PROBLEM. WELL THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM AND A FIX FOR AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY IS A PEJORATIVE AND IT
IS IN THE EYE OF THE BEHOLDER WE
SHOULD NOT RESPOND TO OUR
COLLECTIVE CHALLENGES BY JUMPING
ON THE FAD OF THE DAY AND HOPE
THAT THIS WILL BE THE FIX THE
FIX THAT EVERYBODY IS LOOKING
FOR AND THAT HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO
BY SOME OF THE SUPPORTERS OF
RANKED CHOICE VOTING. WE HAVE
TRIED FADS IN THE PAST THEY HAVE
NOT WORKED. IN SHORT MISTER
CHAIR. AB TWO EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
PRESERVES OUR DEMOCRACY AND
PROTECT CALIFORNIA VOTERS BY
SAYING NO TO RANKED CHOICE
VOTING. AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. BUT I HAVE NO
WITNESSES OFFICE. THANK YOU SIR
I DON'T KNOW WITNESSES- PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I DO SEE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. RESTORE ROSE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME FORWARD. WE HAVE
MISS MISS RUTH DAWSON FROM THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION. ON THE
PHONE LINE IS ROSY MAY BEGIN
HENEVER YOU ARE READY. AND WE
ALSO HAVE DISTRICT HEALTH CARE
AND AS A POSSIBLE EXPERT WITNESS
IF NECESSARY THE COMPANY HAS
QUESTIONS. WHICH WAS CLEAR
BEFOREHAND. MAY NOT BE NECESSARY
MORNING CHAIR BRIAN MEMBERS
AMADOR ROSE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL. CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN BUILDING A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY WE HAVE
A LOT OF NEW OF RULES THAT
REALLY MOVE THAT BALL FORWARD.
AB TWO EIGHT AWAY GOES IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY BUT STRONGLY OPPOSE
IT RANKED CHOICE VOTING HAS BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFULLY USED A LOCAL
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS SO I TAKE ISSUE
WITH THE IDEA THAT IT'S JUST A
FAD. IT HAS A NUMBER OF
ADVANTAGES WINNING CANDIDATES
ARE ELECTED WITH MAJORITY
SUPPORT A SINGLE ACTION WITHOUT
THE NEED OR THE EXPENSE OF A RUN
OFF ELIMINATES. ELIMINATES THE
SPOILER EFFECT I MEAN HAVE SOME
WATER- SO THE WINNER IS A BETTER
REFLECTION OF VOTERS PREFERENCES
AND THERE'S N NEED FOR A
PRIMARY SO LOCAL ELECTIONS CAN
BE HELD RIGHT ALONGSIDE THE
STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTION WILL
TURN OUT ITS HIGHEST AND ALSO
VERY. MUCH MORE REPRESENTATIVE.
IN THE BAY AREA RCV. HAS LED TO
MORE WOMEN CANDIDATES OF COLOR
BEING ELECTED TO LOCAL OFFICE IN
IN CITIES WITHOUT RCV. THE
BILL'S FINDINGS CLAIM THAT RCV
IS UNDEMOCRATIC BECAUSE
CANDIDATES WITH A PLURALITY OF
FIRST CHOICE VOTES MAY NOT WIN
IN THE ELECTION. BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY MUCH MORE DEMOCRATIC
THEM PLURALITY WINNER ELECTIONS
BECAUSE IT ENSURES THAT THE
WINNER HAS MAJORITY SUPPORT.
FINDINGS ALSO CLAIMED THAT RCB'S
CONFUSING AND CAUSES VOTERS TO
MAKE MISTAKES BECAUSE- BUT THIS
ACTUALLY JUST RALLY ISN'T
SUPPORTED BY THE DATA THAT WE'VE
SEEN. RCV IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD-
PROCESS VOTERS JUST INDICATE
THEIR FIRST SECOND AND THIRD
CHOICE AND POLLING SHOWS THAT.
VOTERS UNDERSTANDING OF RCV AND
THE OVER VOTE ERROR RATES ARE
ACTUALLY NO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE SEE WITH BOTH PLURALITY IN
TOP TWO. VOTING MOREOVER VOTERS
HAVE INDICATED THAT THEY PREFER
RCV TO THE SYSTEM IT REPLACED
STRONG EVIDENCE VOTER COMFORT
WITH THE SYSTEM. THIS BILL NOT
ONLY BANS FUTURE USE OF OUR TV
IT ALSO REPEALS IT IN SIX CITIES
THAT ARE ALREADY DOING IT.
REPRESENTING MORE THAN ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS- AND IN
THOSE CITIES IT WAS ACTUALLY
DEMOCRATICALLY ADOPTED WITH
OVERWHELMING VOTER SUPPORT 59%
VOTED FOR IT IN SAN FRANCISCO
68% IN OAKLAND. AND MOST
RECENTLY 73% IN ALBANY. THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULDN'T BE OVER
WRITING A BILL THAT HAS THE WILL
OF LOCAL VOTERS TO ADOPT PROGRAM
DEMOCRACY REFORMS THE LEGAL
VOTERS STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION WE URGE A NO VOTE.
AND I BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUE ON
THE EAST FROM THE ACLU IS ON THE
LINE TO TESTIFY. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY SO WE HAVE ROOF
DAWSON ON THE LINE EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATE IF YOU CAN. AND BRUCE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. BUT
EIGHT GOOD MORNING CAROLINA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY HUNDRED THOUSAND WITH A
VALUE CALIFORNIA ACTION AND LIKE
BELIEVE WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO AB TWO EIGHT AWAIT ESPECIALLY
THE TIME AND VOTING RIGHTS ARE
UNDER ATTACK ACROSS THE COUNTRY
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT PASSED
LEGISLATION PROHIBITING THE
VOTING REFORM THEY CAN DELIVER
BETTER REPRESENTATION AND MARK
FAIR ELECTORAL UP. ESPECIALLY
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
WOMEN AND OTHER MARGINALIZED
GROUPS I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THREE
WAYS RCV CONTRIBUTE TO MARKET
THE PROPERTY FIRST I THINK
IMPROVE DEMOCRATIC PARTICIPATION
BY ALL GROUPS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITH STARKLY DIFFERENT. ADMINS
ROAD THE PLANES ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF OUR TV IS
THAT IT CAN DETERMINE A MAJORITY
WINNER AND A SINGLE HIGH TURN
OUT ELECTION BY ELIMINATING THE
NEED FOR A PRIMARY LOCAL
ELECTIONS CAN BE CONSOLIDATED
WITH NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION
WHEN TURNOUT IS MORE THAN THIRTY
PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER ON
AVERAGE AND SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES PRECIPITATION IN THE
MARKETS THREE GENERAL ELECTIONS
OUR OFFICE ARE MORE
REPRESENTATIVE. OF YOUNG PEOPLE
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE SECOND
ARE HAS ONE TO MARKET RAPPER. AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. I TO TWENTY
STUDY BEAR ELECTION I'M THAT
WENT. HAVE WON BOTH STARTS THE
DELUXE. IN FACT WOMEN DROPPING.
ON CITY. ATTEMPT HIGHER IN BEING
CITY OR YOU THINK HE'D BE. AND
ANOTHER FOUND THAT CAN BE OF
COLOR IN THE AREA OF ONE. 2% OF
WILL A LOT ELECTION COULD BE
ADOPTION OUR- COMPARED WITH ONLY
38% PRIOR. TO OUR HEAT
INTERACTION. AND THIRD THE MALL
SEATS OF OUR- ALSO IMPORTANT
VOTING RIGHTS TO ALL THE COMBAT
THE DIFFERENCE. BY OF COMING OF
COLOR WHETHER IT'S RACIALLY
POLARIZED VOTING. IN FACT THE U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
RECENTLY USED TO MARKET THE RCD
OF THE VOTING RIGHTS REMEDY. AND
EIGHTY TWO WAIT WAIT WOULD TAKE
THE TOOL COMPLETELY OFF THE
TABLE. HAVE A BETWEEN WITH
PREVENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MEETING MORE REPRESENTATIVE BUT
TIME. COULD LEAD TO A DECREASE
REPRESENTATION FOR WOMEN AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND WOULD
BAN A POTENTIAL CIVIL RIGHTS
REMEDY WE RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A COMMENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC OF- ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO COME UP AND
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. FOLLOW LEE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
ELECTORAL REFORM WITH SO MANY
BENEFITS TO VOTERS AND
CANDIDATES WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. ANY TELL%
AT THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. HER
NAME IS CITY WHEREVER I'M MORE
INTO HATS TODAY FIRST ON THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAY A SONG FOR
PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY OF
CALIFORNIA WERE IN OPPOSED THIS
BILL SECONDLY I'M THE ONE OF THE
VICE PRESIDENTS OF CARA
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS IT'S NOT ON THE LIST
BUT WE'RE ALSO VOTED TO OPPOSE-
AB. TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN WE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY EIGHT AWAIT
. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF OR
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE THIRTY TWO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY.
NINE THIRTY TWO WE SEEM TO HAVE
LOST TO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO RE
QUEUE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE'LL
GO TO LINE SIXTY TWO. YES THIS
IS NICOLO DELUCA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND MAYOR
LIBBY SCHAAF IN OPPOSITION. THE
OAKLAND CITY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. BERKELEY MAYOR JESSE
ERROR GAIN IN OPPOSITION AT THE
BERKELEY CITY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY ONE. NUMBER THE
STATE POLICE FROM ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA WERE IN NAPA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SHARING THEMSELVES ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY CLERK'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE.
FIFTY BRITISH CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I KNOW IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT AWAY. NINE
ELEVEN. THIS IS LORALAI MOST
KROGER FROM SANTA BARBARA IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY EIGHT AWAY
. NINE FORTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS DAVID O'BRIEN FROM
REPRESENT US IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
EIGHT- IT THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTEEN JOHNNY PANEER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY THREE. HELLO THIS IS KYLE
BROWN- CITIZEN AND ALSO WITH
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER REPORT PARTY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. LINE.
TWENTY GOOD MORNING MANY MEMBERS
THIS IS SCOTT ALLEN WITH INLAND
EMPIRE UNITED OR UNITED POSTED
AB TWENTY HOURS THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY FIVE. BOB BIRCHARD IN
LARKSPUR IN MARIN COUNTY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
EIGHT AWAY THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS TODD
YOU AND I LIVE IN TO HATCH BEING
KERN COUNTY I AM IN OPPOSITION
AB TWO EIGHT ZERO EIGHT. THANK
YOU. BY. TWENTY SIX. THIS IS OUR
AGUIAR-CURRY I'M A BUSINESS
OWNER AND A CITIZEN OF ORANGE
COUNTY I AM A STRONG OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT. LINE
TWENTY EIGHT. CURRENT PLAYING
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
IN OPPOSITION. LINE. FIFTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS JOHN LONG BILL
CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES WHAT CALLING
TODAY IN MY CAPACITY AS A PAST
MEMBER OF THIS ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE INCLUDING
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE FROM TWO
THOUSAND ONE KILLED TWO THOUSAND
FOUR. I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY EIGHT OO AH WITH THAT
WOULD TAKE AWAY A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO CONTROL.
LINE TWENTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS
EVAN MINTON WITH VOICES FOR
PROGRESS WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
SEVEN. YES HELLO GOOD MORNING
FEATHER NONDESCRIPT CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. NINE THIRTY TWO. I AM
THORUGH SOME LARGEST START AT
FIFTY FOUR RANDOM PERSON OUT
HERE IN APPARENTLY GOOD COMPANY
THINKING THIS IS AN ABSURD BILL
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOUNG
KID. LINE SIXTY SEVEN STEVE
CHESSEN MOUNTAIN VIEW CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. BY. TWENTY ONE. HELLO
GUY CAMIL LERI WITH RANKS OF
BOTH AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RICHARD STUDY COALITION FROM LOS
ANGELES STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. NINE SEVEN. JUNEJA
RESIDENTS OF THE CITY OF
PENTICTON RIVERSIDE COUNTY VERY
STRONGLY. LINE. FIFTY THREE.
NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE THIS IS
WARMLY OF LOS ANGELES THE
BUSINESS OWNER IN CALIFORNIA I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF ANY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR. I SEE MISTER MISTER MAY
. BOB SO IN THIS BILL FIRST CAME
UP I WAS LIKE WHAT THE HELL
O'DONNELL- BUT IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO BUT THE
IMPACT I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
RANKED CHOICE VOTING PICK I
THINK WE SHOULD AT B. X.
EXPANDING AT THIS- OF COURSE OF
THE AUTHOR- IS OF IS A GOOD AS A
GOOD FRIEND OF A- HIGH REGARD
FOR HIM- AND- HIS- HIS PASSION-
FOR THINGS YOU CAN TELL HE'S
PASSIONATELY OPPOSED TO RANK
CHOICE VOTING BUT I'M PASSIONATE
IN FAVOR OF RANKED CHOICE VOTING
IN FACT I THINK IT'S A TOOL THAT
WE SHOULD BE USING TO FURTHER-
OUR OUR DEMOCRACY- NOT NOT NOT
LIMITED SO I WILL BE OPPOSING.
THIS BILL TODAY. I SMALL I THINK
WE SHARE THANK YOU MR DOLLAR PRE
SHEET THE- PASSION OF YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT- I WON'T BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY I
WAS ACTUALLY REMINDED BY
URINALYSIS THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS I SHOULD SAY. THAT MY
FATHER WAS ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
AUTHORS ALONG WITH- MISTER
LANDAU ON RANKED CHOICE VOTING
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. A
NUMBER OF BAY AREA JURISDICTIONS
HAVE RANKED CHOICE VOTING IN
PLACE- I DO THINK THE DATA IS
COMPELLING THAT THE ELECTION
RESULTS. OF A RESERVE RESULT IN.
A CANDIDATES GETTING ELECTED
THAT BETTER REPRESENT THE
POPULATIONS AS A WHOLE- THAT
THERE IS DIVERSIFICATION AND OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS PULL- I THINK
THAT'S ALL PRETTY COMPELLING IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE- IN CALIFORNIA WE WANT
GOVERNING BODIES THAT. BETTER
REPRESENT OF THE PUBLIC THEY
SERVE- SO I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. WITH WITH THE CABBIE
OUT THAT THIS FEEL STILL. LIKE
WE'RE IN THE EXPERIMENTAL PHASE%
TO SOME DEGREE. I THINK IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A LITTLE WHILE TO
SEE WHAT THE OVERALL NET EFFECT
IS BUT I THINK THE EARLY RESULTS
ARE VERY ENCOURAGING SELL- AS A
AS A SUPPORTER OF RANKED CHOICE
VOTING. I CAN'T BE WITH YOU
TODAY MR DAUDA BUT APPRECIATE TO
YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THESE ISSUES
THAT I KNOW AS A- FORMER
GOVERNMENT TEACHER I KNOW YOU
CARE ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND THE
SON OF A FORMER GOVERNMENT
TEACHER WHO HAS. MANY OF THE
SAME AIMS IN TERMS AIMS IN TERMS
OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. ON AND
pDEGREE OUR OUR IMPERFECT
DEMOCRACY BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MAKE THREE COMMENTS. THANK YOU.
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR UP. I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
LINE THAT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN JUST ENDED WITH WHICH IS
FOR TRYING TO PERFECT ARE IN
PERFECT MARKER C. AND SO WAS OF
THAT REQUIRES DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION AND CERTAINLY GET
MISTER O'DONNELL I. RESPECTTHE
POSITION YOU YOU BRING ON THIS
IN TERMS OF- A GOVERNMENT
TEACHER AND DEALING WITH THOSE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND HAVING
THOSE QUESTIONS. BUT THERE'S ONE
BENEFIT OF RANKED CHOICE VOTING
THAT I THINK DOES NOT GET
IDENTIFIED ENOUGH AND I THINK
THEY'RE BEEN VERY MANY GOOD
THINGS IDENTIFIED HERE-
PARTICULARLY THE AMOUNT OF
MINORITY REPRESENTATION AND SOME
OF THE OTHER THINGS. THAT I
HAVE. WITNESSED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN- A CITY WHERE A CANDIDATE
WHO HAD NO ABILITYTO GET A
MAJORITY VOTE OF THE CITIZENS OF
THAT CITY TO BE ON THE CITY
COUNCIL. CONSISTENTLY TERM AFTER
TERM WOULD WIN ELECTIONS BECAUSE
A CANDIDATE HAD TWO THINGS GOING
FOR IT THAT HE HAD A SMALL GROUP
MINORITY GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
WERE ALWAYS GOING TO VOTE FOR.
AND HE ALWAYS MADE SURE THAT
THERE ARE LOTS OF CANDIDATES
RUNNING HE WOULD GO OUT AND
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO RUN
BECAUSE THE MORE PEOPLE THAT
RAN. THE MORE HE WAS ASSURED
THAT HIS 28% OF THE VOTERS WAS
GOING TO GUARANTEE HIM A SEAT
AND SO I THINK DEMOCRACY IS NOT
SWELL SERVED WHEN YOU HAVE.
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE CITY
COUNCIL THAT ARE CONSISTENTLY
VOTED AND THEY DO NOT HAVE A
MAJORITY VOTE. THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO EVER GET A
MAJORITY VOTE. AND THAT IS TO ME
THE GREAT BENEFIT OF RANKED
CHOICE VOTING HIS THAT YOU AT
LEAST GET SOMEONE WHO IF IT WAS
DOWN TO TWO PEOPLE. THIS PERSON
WOULD NEVER HAVE WON A TWO
PERSON RACE. I THINK IT IN THE
IN THE CITY THAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT AND SO- WITH THAT- I
CERTAINLY AND MOST. OF IT IS
JUST TIME REMAIN A SUPPORTER OF
RANKED CHOICE VOTING AND- WOULD
LOVE TO. HEAR SOME MORE- OF YOUR
SAJAN SITES ABOUT THE WHOLE
VOTING PROCESS AS IT GOES
FORWARD AND. I'M SINCERE WHEN I
SAY THAT. THANK YOU. RESEARCHERS
ARE. HI- SOME MEMBER O'DONNELL
FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR-
COMMITTING YOURSELF TO TEACHING
OUR KIDS IN HIGH SCHOOL THE
IMPORTANCE OF VOTING WE WANT TO
SPEND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
TODAY TO DO EXACTLY THAT WHEN WE
SHOULD BE DOING THAT HIGH
SCHOOLS SO I APPLIED YOU ARE
YOUR EFFORTS IN THE OTHER
TEACHERS- EFFORTS AS WELL OF MY
ISSUE WITH THIS PARTICULAR BILL
IS A DEFECT ON CHARTER CITIES-
CHARTER CITIES ARE ARE AT A LOT
OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW AND
HOPEFULLY THEY TEACH THAT AND
CIVICS TO THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A GENERAL ON A CHARTER CITY. AND
AT CHARTER CITIES ARE THE WAY
THEY ARE BECAUSE THEY SEEK A
LITTLE MORE ECONOMY- FROM THE
STATE GOVERNMENT- THEN- AND A
CITIZENS AT THAT LIVE THERE-
SEEK THAT ALSO AND- DISALLOWING
THEM TO ENGAGE IN THE RANKED
CHOICE VOTING- I THINK TO ROADS
SOME OF THAT AND- AND THEREFORE-
BECAUSE OF THAT- I BAG. MAN. NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY. GREAT AND I THINK MY
RESPONSE WOULD BE. THAT THE
STATE HAS A DUTY TO PROTECT
DEMOCRACY. IT HAS A DUTY TO
PROTECT VOTING. AND EVEN OF THAT
AMBULANCE ON THE AUTHORITY. OF A
CHARTER CITY TO NOT DO THAT THIS
BILL IS THE RIGHT THING BUT I
APPRECIATE WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM. HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO LINE MY
COMMENTS ALSO WITH- COLLEAGUES
ON THE COMMITTEE THE FIRST
COMMAND THE AUTHOR IT'S NOT
OFTENTIMES YOU'LL SEE THIS THE
AUTHOR THEMSELVES WITHOUT ANY
SPONSORS BUT IT JUST GOES TO
SHOW THAT THE DEEP COMMITMENT
AND THE PASSION THAT YOU HAVE IN
THE PREPARATION AND IDENTIFYING
THESE ISSUES ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR ALLOWING THIS
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD BECAUSE
THIS IS ABOUT DEMOCRACY AND
CONTINUING TO REFLECT ON THE
TYPE OF. ACCESSIBILITY I THINK
AS GOVERNMENT WE HAVE A DUTY AND
AN OBLIGATION SIMILAR IT IS I
KNOW THE OPPOSITION WOULD AGREE
WHICH IS THAT FOR THE EVERYDAY
VOTER TO EXPLAIN TO THEM IN A
COHERENT WAY FOR THE AVERAGE
CITIZEN IS IMPORTANT- AND
TECHNOLOGY THAT THE PROPOUNDS.
THE AUTHOR SOME OF DONALD. AS
OUTLINED SOME DEEP CONFUSION. IN
WHICH IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US AS
GOVERNMENT AND TO HELP EXPLAIN
AND FURTHER EDUCATE AND I KNOW
THAT THIS COMMITTEE WILL STAND
FIRM TO REFER WILL STAND TO
REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
HELPING TO EDUCATE AS MUCH OF
THE PUBLIC AS POSSIBLE TO
INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY. AS WE HAVE VARYING
MODELS AND LOOKING AT THE TYPE
OF RESULTS THAT WE HOPE TO
ACHIEVE SO I JUST WANT TO SHARE
AN ECHO THOSE COMMENTS TO AGAIN
COMMEND THE AUTHOR. FOR ALLOWING
US THIS OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
DIALOGUE AND ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE NEED TO BE DOING MORE OF THE
STATE AND ALSO JURISDICTIONS TO
FURTHER EXPLAIN- AS I ALSO HAIL
FROM THE BAY AREA. A NUMBER OF
FRIENDS FAMILY MEMBERS AND OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WILL ASK THAT
SIMILAR QUESTION. WHAT DOES
TRIGGERING CHOICE AND WHAT IS
THE SECOND VOTE MEAN AND- HOW
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE- SO. I SAY
THAT AGAIN TO BEGIN JUST COMMEND
THE AUTHOR AGAIN. AND LOOK FOR
TO THE COULD YOU DISCUSSION
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU SO
THEM BELOW SAN NO FOR THE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS BY THE
COMMITTEE MISTER LANGLY MAKE LOS
. I'M I TANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST A QUICK CLOSE AND THEN ASK
IF YOU MAY BOB. I'LL JUST
HIGHLIGHT THE REASONS I'M I'M
FORWARDING THIS BILL AGAIN AT
LEAST A VOTER CONFUSION DATA
SHOWS THAT- ESPECIALLY IN
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES SOMEONE
DENY THAT WITH IS ABSOLUTELY A
FACT- DISENFRANCHISES VOTERS
VOTERS END UP OFTENTIMES GIVING
UP. HALFWAY DOWN ABOUT BECAUSE
THERE'S FATIGUE THEY GET
CONFUSED. AS MANY ROUNDS OF
VOTING A GAMING THE VOTE SOME
WOULD LIKE THIS QUITE FRANKLY
ALLOW SPECIAL INTERESTS TO GAME
THE VOTE. MAKE IT LIKE I JUST
MENTIONED EARLIER PREDICTED
VIDEO GAME. IT'S A THREAT TO
MAJORITY RULE I WOULD ACTUALLY
COUNTY MISTER BENNETT THAT OF A
KIM IF A COUNCIL MEMBER CAN'T
GET A MAJORITY VOTE MAYBE IT
SHOULD BE A COUNCILMAN. OKAY I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD CREATE A
MECHANISM- WHEN SOMEONE COULD
BECOME A ACCOUNTS MEMBER WITHOUT
A MAJORITY VOTE SO THAT A
DIFFERENT WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT
ON THAT BUT- WE'RE GOOD MAN WE
CAN DIFFER- BUT AGAIN THIS WILL
NOT FIX THE PROBLEM AND AGAIN
THE PROBLEM. IS IN THE EYE OF
THE BEHOLDER INSTANCE EVERYONE
HERE SO IN LOVE WITH RANKED
CHOICE VOTING. I THINK WE SHOULD. VOTE ON THIS BILL USING RANKED
CHOICE VOTING. SO THE TEACHER IN
ME CAME OVER AN IDEA.
INTERACTIVE EXERCISE HERE. AND
AT THE TOP YOU'LL SEE IT YOU SEE
RIGHT HERE. IT SAYS AB.
208-280-8228 ZERO EIGHT- IN AB
TWO TWO EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
OFFICIAL RCV BALLOTS SO IF
YOU'RE LOOKING HERE THE
INSTRUCTIONS. ARE RANK UP TO SIX
POSITIONS ON THE BILL. I DO NOT
MARK MORE THAN ONE IN EACH
COLUMN. DO NOT MARK MORE THAN
ONE IN EACH ROW. SHOULD THE
COMMITTEE FAILED TO ACHIEVE A
MAJORITY POSITION ON THE BILL OF
POSITION WILL BE ELIMINATED-
NEXT RANK POSITION WILL BE
COUNTED. OKAY ONCE MAJORITY
POSITION HAS BEEN ACHIEVED HER
FINAL POSITION WILL BE RECORDED
AS YOUR OFFICIAL POSITION AS A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE I HOPE
YOU'RE NOT CONFUSED WITH THAT
THANK YOU MR IT EITHER WAY IF
YOU LOOK HERE. THE POSITIONS ARE
ARE YOU IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
SOMEWHAT IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
WANT TO VOTE FOR IT BUT CAN'T.
PARTIALLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
OPPOSED TO THE FOUR CONFUSE
THOSE YOUR CHOICES I HOPE WE CAN
USE THE O'DONNELL METHODOLOGY
TODAY MISTER CHAIR TO VOTE ON
THIS BILL BECAUSE RANKED CHOICE
VOTING IS SO WONDERFUL ON
UNFORTUNATELY. WE WOULD NEED A
MOTION FIRST BUT- I HOPE YOU DO
THIS EXERCISE AND IN THE
CLASSROOM THAT YOU'LL RETURN TO
ONCE A GOVERNMENT TEACHER ALWAYS
A GOVERNMENT TEACHER AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT. ALSO LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES I SEE YOUR PASSION
AND- YOUR PERSONAL. INTEREST IN
ENSURING THAT OUR DEMOCRACY IS
FUNCTIONAL- AND HAS A HIGH
EFFICACY AS HIGH THE NEXT IF
THIS IS POSSIBLE USE RANKED
CHOICE VOTING I WAS ALREADY
LIMITED. ONLY TO CHARTER CITIES.
BUT DISTINCT MEANS THEY'RE ALSO
ADDITIONAL TWO CHARTER CITIES
THAT VOTED THROUGH BALLOT
MEASURES IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
APPROVE. THE USE OF RANKED
CHOICE VOTING IN FUTURE
ELECTIONS AND SO I SEE AN
INHERENT CONTRADICTION. IN
ENSURING DEMOCRACY BY UNDOING
THE WILL AND LOCAL CONTROL OF
DEMOCRACY THAT'S ALREADY TAKING
PLACE. AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY. IS THERE A MOTION TO
MOVE THIS BILL. I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE COMMENT I'D NOT MAKING A
MOTION WITH THE BILL I JUST
WANNA CORRECT ONE SHORT. MR NOW
I'M GONNA GO BACK AND FORTH MR
NOW ARE THEY NOT MAKE THE CUT
THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU. SO NO
MOTION MISTER CHAIR SINGLE
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL THAT
THIS BILL REMAINS IN COMMITTEE
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THE BILL. COULD YOU
COULD SAY I DON'T WANNA HEAR THE
BILL BECAUSE I GET THIS CAN
CONTROVERSIAL VOTES. BUT AGAIN-
I APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS A-
GREAT. DEMOCRATIC EXERCISE WERE
ENGAGED IN RIGHT HERE. AND RIGHT
NOW SO I THANK YOU AND I THINK
THE OPPONENTS TO. THANK YOU MISS
OUT ON THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW MOVES TO THE FINAL ITEM
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. AND THAT'S A.
B. TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. THANK YOU
SO THE NUMBER AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
TURNER AND COLLEAGUES THIS HELPS
TO ENSURE THAT THE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FORTY ONE INSURERS THERE
ARE NOTICE OF REGISTRATION
CANCELLATION AND HELPING TO
SERVE. OUR POPULATIONS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY VOTE TODAY
WITH ME AND A BRIEF COMMENTS AS
BRITNEY STARTS A FOR FROM ACLU
AND DORO SPEND WE GET OF WOMEN
VOTERS WELL PEOPLE MAY KICK IT
OFF. MORE TO RUN MEMBERS. I'M
AROSA AND VOTERS TO CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF AB TWO
EIGHT FOUR ONE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND THANK
YOU TO SOMEONE OVER LOW FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT PRO
DEMOCRACY BILL. I'M GOING TO
SPEAK TO THE PART OF THE BILL
THAT PREVENTS INAPPROPRIATE
VOTER PURGES AND MY ACLU KALI
BRODICK BRITNEY STONECIPHER IS
GOING TO SPEAK TO THE
CONSERVATIVE SHIP SHIP ASPECTS
OF THE LEGISLATION. SO REGULAR
VOTER ROLL MAINTENANCE REQUIRES
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO REMOVE
PEOPLE FROM THE ROLLS FOR
VARIETY OF REASONS RIGHT
INCLUDING PRISON COMMITMENT.
COURT DETERMINE MENTAL
INCOMPETENCY DEATH OR BECAUSE
THEY'VE MOVED AND NOT RESPONDED
TO AN UPDATE REQUEST WITHIN FOUR
YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY ERRORS IN
THE PIPELINE OF REPORTING
SYSTEMS CAN RESULT IN FALSE
MATCHES BETWEEN DIFFERENT
AGENCIES RECORDS AND ALSO- EGGS
SOMETIMES CAUSES ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TO RELY ON OVER
INCLUSIVE LISTS WHEN THAT
HAPPENS WE END UP
DISENFRANCHISES VOTERS AND IT'S
VOTERS WERE ALREADY HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED. BLACK VOTERS
BROWN VOTERS AND THOSE WHO ARE
LOW INCOME AND YOUNG WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IMPACTED BY
THESE A RONI IS VOTER
REGISTRATION CANCELLATION SO
HUGE. PROBLEM THERE IN TERMS OF
EQUITY. NOW IN THE- OF REGULAR
VOTER ROLL MAINTENANCE PEOPLE
ARE SOMETIMES SWITCH TO WHAT'S
CALLED INACTIVE STATUS WHEN
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT THEY'VE
MOVED ADDRESSES. IF THAT HAPPENS
I NOTICE GOES OUT FOR YEARS
BEFORE THE ACTUAL CANCELLATION
RIGHT FOUR YEARS TO LET FOLKS
KNOW THAT THE REGISTRATION IS
GOING TO BE CANCELLED IF THEY
DON'T VOTE OR UPDATE THEIR
REGISTRATION WITHIN THAT NEXT
FOUR YEARS. BUT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT TO LET VOTERS KNOW
THAT THEIR REGISTRATIONS
ACTUALLY BEING CANCELED FOR THAT
ADDRESS CHANGE PROCESS. AND
PEOPLE WERE BEING CANCELED DUE
TO THINGS LIKE METAL. THE COURT
JUDGMENT OF MENTAL INCOMPETENCY
OR INCARCERATION THEY DON'T
RECEIVE ANY KIND OF NOTIFICATION
AT ALL SO AB TWO EIGHT FOUR ONE
WOULD REQUIRE NOTIFICATION
IMMEDIATELY BEFORE CANCELLATION.
I WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE A CHANCE
TO ADDRESS A PROBLEMS OF THAT
ARE- COMING UP. SO STUDIES
INDICATE THAT MULTIPLE
COMMUNICATIONS PLUS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE THE PROBLEM
CAN BE ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAYS TO PREVENT
DISENFRANCHISEMENT. AB TWO EIGHT
FOUR ONE IS A VERY COMMON SENSE
BILL IT JUST NOTIFIES VOTERS AND
PROVIDES THEM THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO STOP MISTAKING CANCELLATIONS
BEFORE THEY ACTUALLY OCCUR. WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO BRITNEY TO TALK
ABOUT THE CONSERVATORSHIP ASPECT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THE
MORNING COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
BERNIE STONECIPHER WITH ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA ACTION. IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY NOT A VOTERS
DISABILITIES WERE 6% LESS LIKELY
TO VOTE THAN THE OVERALL VOTER
POPULATION. FOR VOTERS OF THE
MENTAL OR COGNITIVE DISABILITY
THAT TURNED OUT GAP IS ALMOST
SEVENTEEN PERCENT. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS PASSED
REFORMS IN RECENT YEARS AIMED AT
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
ELIGIBLE VOTERS WERE PLACED INTO
THE CARE OF CONSERVADOR. HOWEVER
OUTDATED REPORTING SYSTEMS AND
MISINFORMATION ARE PRESENTLY
UNDERMINING THAT'S PROTECTIONS.
PEOPLE MAY BE PLACED UNDER
CONSERVATORSHIP FOR MANY REASONS
AND BY LAW THEY RETAIN THEIR
VOTING RIGHTS UNLESS THE COURT
FINDS THAT THEY CANNOT
COMMUNICATE A DESIRE TO VOTE
INCLUDING WITH REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS. BUT TROUBLING
HOWEVER WHETHER A PERSON UNDER
CONSERVATORSHIP HAS THEIR VOTING
RIGHTS REVOKED MAY DEPEND MORE
ON WHICH COUNTY THEY LIVE IN.
THEN ON WHETHER THEY'RE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE THEIR INTEREST IN
VOTING. COUNTY COURTS REPORT
CONSERVATORSHIP BREAK VOTING
RIGHTS CHANGES AN ALARMINGLY A
REGULAR AND UNCLEAR MANNER. THIS
MAY BE BECAUSE ABOUT HALF OF
COURTS ARE NOT USING THE
STANDARDIZED YEAH OPTIONAL FORM
THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
CREATED FOR THEM. AND SEVERAL
COUNTY STILL APPEAR TO BE RUBBER
STAMPING VOTING RIGHTS REMOVAL
AND NEARLY ALL CONSERVATORSHIP
CASES. THESE PRACTICE RISK
PRACTICES RAISE SERIOUS RED
FLAGS AND YET CURRENT LAW
DOESN'T REQUIRE VOTERS UNDER
CONSERVATORSHIP TO BE INFORMED
WHEN THEIR RIGHTS ARE EITHER
REVOKED OR REINSTATED. AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY ONE WILL CURB FAULTY
CANCELLATIONS BY STANDARDIZING
REPORTING PROCEDURES AND
PROVIDING NOTICE TO AFFECTED
VOTERS. SB FIVE A FORMER SIGNED
INTO LAW LAST WEEK CREATING
NEARLY IDENTICAL REPORTING
SYSTEMS AND RESTORATION NOTICES
FOR VOTERS WITH CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ENSURE THESE BEST PRACTICES ARE
ALSO IN PLACE TO PREVENT PROTECT
ELIGIBLE VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND FINALLY AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ONE WILL
IMPROVE ACCOUNTABILITY BY
TRACKING THE PERCENT OF
CONSERVATORSHIP. THE RESULT
RESULT AND VOTING RIGHTS REMOVAL
AND PROVIDING TRAINING RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT COUNTIES. CALIFORNIA
MUST STOP THE AVOIDABLE
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF ELIGIBLE
VOTERS FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
YOUR OF THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. SING NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL UBLIC COMMENT
STARTING WITH PEOPLE HERE IN THE
SAME ROOM AS ANYBODY IN THE
HEARING ROOM. WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON AB TWENTY FORTY ONE.
SIGNAL NOW MOVES TO THE PHONE
LINES. OPERATOR THERE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU AND IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FORTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO DO AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE GONNA LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SANTIAGO WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT ONE NUMBER SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR THANK THE
PART. NUMBER LINE NUMBER TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
SCOTT ALLEN WITH UNITED. CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. VENTURE
PERCENT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL NOT TURN OVER THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF ANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD. WISH TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL. SEEING NONE MISTER
LUCKY MAY CLOSE. THAT'S JUST-WANT TO CLARIFY TAKING THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE
. NO NO JUST KIDDING CHECK FOR A
RIVAL. THE TEAM AND I WE ARE
FANS OF THIS BILL AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT
FORWARD- THIS BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
MADAMS THAT IS THEIR MOST OF
THIS BILL. BY MISS RUBIO. AND
MASSACRED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BRIAN BRIAN I
SEYARTO NO SEYARTO NO BENNETT
BENNETT I LOW LOW I MAYES MAYES
MULLIN. MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO.
NO I. SIX THE DOOR GOES UP AND-
THANK YOU. ONE MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL FOR SOME
VOTE ADAMS. ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIVE SEVEN SIX BY AGUILAR CURRY-
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. LOW I WANT
TO RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I. SO
THAT'S GOING TO ONE YEAH TWO ONE
SEVEN TWO NATURE. I'M ON AB
SIXTEEN NINETEEN I CERVANTES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BENNETT. SENATE I
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I. I
AM THREE AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
TWO BY SERVAN TESTS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BENNETT. BENNETT
I LO. LO I BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO I. REPUBLICAN. THAT'S
EVERYTHING THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.